et la vidéothèque de paris nous fournit
chaque jour d'autres images sur la
libération de la capitale
une libération à laquelle ont largement
contribué les premières radios libres
images rassemblées par gérard dalmas
tandis qu'à londres une équipe nous
apporte l'espoir notre réconfort
quotidien à paris une autre équipe
dirigée par jean gilbert prépare dans la
clandestinité la libération des ondes
et lorsque fin ou 1944 les allemands
entreprennent leur grand exode
la résistance s'organise à paris et que
le premier appel aux armes et à capter
l'équipe que dirige jean gilbert
s'apprêtent à parler malgré la présence
des allemands alors c'est vrai tout est
prêt j'ai fait mes chers amis au courant
alors on va démarrer
qu'est-ce qui fait la première et longue
je pense qu'elle brille en droit canon
mongiat finlande taule c'est bien pour
toi vas toi tu vas là c est pierre ménès
lance le premier appel radio diffusée
ici radiodiffusion française
le comité d'action militaire du conseil
national de la résistance et l'état
major national des forces françaises de
l'intérieur adressé à la population
parisienne l'appel que voici les troupes
alliées sont à proximité de paris
l'ennemi traquer bat en retraite avec
les débris d'unités démoraliser les
forces françaises de l'intérieur se sont
magnifiquement battu suivant l'exemple
de la france entière
l'heure est venue de chasser
définitivement l'ennemi de la capitale
la population tout entière doit se
soulever
la préfecture de police centre de la
résistance et assiégée par les forces
allemand cependant que le nouveau préfet
de police monsieur luizet parvient à
pénétrer dans l'enceinte et à prendre le
commandement de ses coûts aussitôt les
reporters de la radiodiffusion sont là
pour l'interview
voyez écouter la première déclaration de
monsieur charles visait préfet de police
regardez bien à l'arrière-plan entre le
journaliste et le préfet lui there un
certain edgard pisani sous-préfets
depuis quelques instants
24 août
tard le soir les premiers libérateur la
2e db surtout sont annoncés par la porte
d'orléans à paris la ville aux 54 porte
pierre crainey sans trembler d'émotion
et communiquent
aussitôt la merveilleuse nouvelle car
curieusement le téléphone lui un presque
toujours fonctionné du standard oui je
n'ai pas de micro voulez vous
enregistrer immédiatement mon téléphone
attention je commence j'ai quitté il ya
quelques instants
la préfecture de police de paris je suis
arrivée place de l'hôtel de ville et je
suis encore très ému c'est surtout
maintenant que je réalise la grandeur de
ce que j'ai vu en plein coeur de paris
j'ai vu deux chars de la division
leclerc avant garde cela revêt la
génération a libéré